[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY BENNETT: [INAUDIBLE].
Awesome.
So in celebration of
Black History Month,
members of the Black
Googler Network in Ann Arbor
created a film that explores
their past experiences
as it pertains to their initial
realizations of being black.
This project was inspired
by the 2017 CNN featurette,
"The First Time I
Realized I Was Black,"
and the 1903 book
by W. E. B. Du Bois
entitled "The Souls
of Black Folk."
We just finished watching an
incredibly powerful film that
showcases some
poignant experiences
that black people in America
face on a daily basis.
And I'm honored to
have the opportunity
to unpack these stories
here today with Stephanie.
So let's get started.
There are a few stories that
point out a specific moment
where a physical feature or a
sense of identity beyond just
the color of someone's
skin was a primary catalyst
for the interviewees'
personal experience.
So we're talking about
hair, the clothes,
the origin of their name even.
With your focus being
on diversity, equity,
and inclusion, particularly
in hierarchies of education,
how would you say
these catalysts could
be potential
obstacles or pitfalls
in the black experience
in terms of education
or professional environments?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Sure.
So I want to say something
first about context.
I think it's really important
to be clear about the context.
The interviewees weren't just
talking about their experiences
of being black within their
home communities where everyone
else identified the same way.
We're talking about
the first time
mainly that folks
realized they were
black coming into contact
with those who were different
than them, what it's like to
be black in America, what it's
like to be black in the context
of racism and white supremacy.
So I want to be
clear about that.
And so when we're
talking about racism
or any form of oppression,
there's a dominant culture.
There's the dominant
culture and there's
the culture around which
we determine what's
normal and good, and
everything outside of that
can be seen as having less
value or no value at all.
So these catalysts
that you mentioned,
whether they're hair or
clothes, they become pitfalls
when they're put in the context
of the dominant culture,
and the dominant culture
isn't OK with that.
So those pitfalls aren't just
pitfalls in and of themselves.
I want to make sure that we're
talking about that in context.
So we see this coming up anytime
we see black folks coming
into contexts with institutions
where whiteness has been
the norm, and those catalysts
signal otherness in a way
that the dominant
culture isn't OK with.
So we see that when we're
interviewing for jobs,
and a particular name means
we don't get a call back,
or we see that when our dress
is disciplined through dress
codes, or we see that when we're
disproportionately punished
or pushed out of schools.
And so those things add
up in the sort of minute,
even though they're
not minute, instances.
But they add up over time.
And they keep us from
gaining access to places.
advancing in the places
that we do gain access to.
Yeah.
BRADY BENNETT: Absolutely.
Awesome.
So, additionally, we see that
many of these experiences
can stem from just a pure
misconception of a black person
as an individual or even beyond
that black people in general.
So when we look
back on the film,
there was this idea of
good black, bad black,
ghetto, not ghetto, et cetera.
But tying into that
previous question--
what could be the effects or
outcomes of the experiences
on black people and in
what ways, if any at all,
can we combat clarify
these misperceptions.
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah, so in
my field-- so in intergroup
relations we talk
a lot about how
people understand themselves as
parts of various social groups
and either belonging or
not belonging to groups.
So we know that people
tend to view folks
within their own group as
more favorable than out-group.
And we also know that
it's incredibly difficult
to change folks perception
of those in the out-group,
even when positive images
of those in the out-group
are presented to them.
So that's why we
see what we see--
we-- as was noted in the film.
We see people continuing
to have experiences
with either white folks or
non-black folks of color
where they're confronted with
those stereotypes coming back
to them in a negative way no
matter what they're presenting.
But we need to remember that
those cognitive processes--
these processes of figuring
out who's in the in-group
and who's in the out-group,
again, may happen in context.
We're not just finding
out where we belong
and where we don't, we're
finding out where we belong
and where we don't in
the context of racism.
And so that means that our
institutions are constantly
giving us messages
about who matters
and who doesn't, who's
in and who's out.
What I think is really
hopeful about that,
and to answer your
question about what
we can do to combat it--
it means that these
things aren't innate.
These senses of who's in
and who's out, who belongs
and who doesn't, they're
not necessarily innate.
They are part of the messages
that are constantly reinforced
by our various
institutions-- be they
schools, be their
corporations, be
they the criminal legal system.
And so if they're not
innate, if they're learned,
that means that they
can be unlearned.
And so when you're talking
about what we can do,
I think that we begin to learn--
when we start to create
different institutions--
different social, political,
economic structures--
that have different
messages about who matters,
and who doesn't,
and so then we start
to internalize those messages
as opposed to the ones that
have been internalized.
Everyone, I think, can take
part in that in different ways.
But I do think that's possible.
BRADY BENNETT: Awesome.
So taking a look at
each of these stories,
we also noticed this realization
of blackness or being different
and how it comes in
many different forms.
We saw the very overt,
loud ways and even
some of the more
subtle, covert ones when
it comes to racial epithets,
being watched, or followed,
even questioned.
With that in mind,
what ways can you
say this can alter the
mannerisms or presentation
of black people that they
give off in order just
to validate their right to
be somewhere or even maintain
their own personal safety.
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah.
So I want to say there's a
range of ways that people react
to oppression and what we saw
in the film is representative
of that range.
Sometimes we respond by trying
to educate someone else,
trying to let them
know why I'm different
or we're different than
a particular stereotype.
Sometimes we shut down.
Sometimes we are in shock
and we're not really sure
how to respond.
And sometimes our response
is fear and that's
very legitimate
given what we know
about how racist violence
shows up in spaces.
But I think that
the interviewees
pointed to a dilemma that
lots of us can relate to,
many black folks
can relate to having
to think about choices of
our presentation, our style,
the way we dress, the way we
speak, who we interact with,
or what we should do to
make others comfortable
or, at the very least,
incite less fear,
if we feel like that's
what we need to do.
We can definitely be made to
feel that way in the context
that we're in.
And I think they--
those messages come
and they've been
internalized by us,
they've internalized by
folks in our communities,
and they have real impacts.
I still live with folks--
live amongst folks who think
that pulling up your pants
and straightening your
hair is the thing to do,
but, and to be fair,
they've probably
lived through
experiences where that
might have been true for them.
But what I want to say about
that is we know there's a cost
to that-- to those of
us who have to do it--
for those of us who are faced
with that dilemma constantly
of having to change-- or
whether to change our hair,
change our style or dress,
change the way that we speak,
change who we associate with--
that comes at a
psychological cost
us, that comes at an emotional
cost to us, that comes
at an intellectual cost to us.
And we know that it
doesn't necessarily work,
that it doesn't actually
chip away at the systems
that we're living in.
It doesn't do anyone any favors
in terms of restructuring
the systems that we're in.
So, yes, I want to say those
impacts are definitely real
and we know that the ways that
we're pressured to shift--
succumbing to that
pressure-- doesn't help us
and it doesn't shift the
places that we're living in.
BRADY BENNETT: Absolutely.
Now, I guess, with all of
that being said, for those
who are on the outside looking
in on these experiences
that black or minority
communities endure
on a daily basis, what would
you say the role of an ally
could be in efforts to dispel
those misconceptions and combat
moments like the ones
mentioned in the film
in a supportive
or productive way?
STEPHANIE HICKS:
So I think allies--
and in this case allies
to people of color,
I'm talking about white folks
and in certain situations
other non-black folks of color.
I think the most supportive
and productive work they can do
is realize the work
they have to do
within themselves and
in their communities
and let that be their focus.
So white and non-white
folks of color
should ask themselves
how they're
implicated in a racist society.
What-- how have they benefited?
How have they participated
in these systems
actively or passively?
It is impossible
to be in a society
that we're in without
breathing in the fog of that--
of these systems.
So I think the
thing that folks can
do is really focus on
their participation,
and focus on how they've
benefited, and focus on the--
on that type of work.
When you're asking
yourselves those--
when you're asking
yourselves those questions,
that leads you to the
places you should go,
which is to other folks who
want to band up with you
and push back against
these systems.
And then you can do it from
a more empathetic place.
So if you're doing
your own work,
if you're focused on the
internal work that you have
to do, and the work that you
have to do within your own
communities-- not necessarily
about being the best ally
or being the most down person--
it puts you in a place
to be empathetic,
so when your
friend's mom says, I
don't want my child
playing with black folks,
you can say, hey, Suzy
or whoever, I too--
I know-- we've been
in the same community,
we've grown up in
the same place,
I know we've gotten
those same messages,
why don't we think
about how we can
unpack that as opposed to
maybe some of the other ways
that we see folks intervening,
which is much more about maybe
making sure that they
appear to be the best ally
or seen that way by others.
BRADY BENNETT: Absolutely.
And I guess, just as far
as my final question--
I think it would
be remiss of me not
to ask, of course, with
this being the case,
but Stephanie, what
is the first time you
realized you were black?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah.
So I was thinking about this
and like was mentioned--
as was mentioned in
the film, I grew up
in a black space, black
community, black schools,
black extracurricular
activities.
And so I think I had a pretty
deep sense of being proud
of my blackness
when I was younger.
When I went to
middle school, it was
the first time I'd
gone to a racially
integrated middle school--
and the thing to do was
read "Seventeen" magazine.
But this is like the late '90s,
so I went from being obsessed
with Aaliyah and trying to
wear my hair over one eye to--
the thing was beach waves--
the girls on the
covers of magazines
was supposed have beach waves.
And so I remember I had this
edition of "Seventeen" magazine
and it was all about
how to get beach waves.
And so I bought all
this stuff, and it
was like spray your
roots, and blow dry it.
And so I tried to do
this and my mom just
watched me wear
myself out with this.
And she goes-- and
I was, like, mom,
I can't do want I
want-- beach waves.
And she just goes, you're
black, get over it.
And it was one of
those and-- but she
said it in this way that
wasn't necessarily punishing,
it was, like, this is who you
are and that's not a thing.
I'm going to let you
have your moment,
but this is different
than what you have
and what you have
to offer, so that
was one of the first moments.
But I will say, in the context
of what I do every day--
I'm a faculty member
on a university campus.
And I think I'm reminded often
of my blackness in the same way
that lots of folks
mentioned in the film.
I constantly-- I'm in
spaces where I may be,
not the only person of color,
but the only black person,
or I'm the only black woman,
or I'm definitely the youngest
person by a long shot.
So I'm-- so I'm reminded
in that way as well--
that those are some moments.
Yeah.
BRADY BENNETT: Awesome.
I guess when you
point that out, I
see there's,
obviously, the very two
different distinctions
of that realization,
but going to the
former of those--
getting that initial
identification
from someone in
your familiar group,
how does that experience
vary from, like you said,
the everyday experiences
that you have now.
STEPHANIE HICKS:
Yeah, so I think
in that instance with my mom--
I'm her child and I was her
daughter, her black daughter,
who was an image
of her and someone
that she had raised to
be very proud of that.
And so her reminding--
her reminder of my blackness
was one that was out of love--
this is-- these are all the
things that you should embrace,
even though you're
not maybe reflected
in some of the dominant
images that we see.
What you have is still
beautiful and valuable.
I think, compared to the latter
instances, maybe my blackness
sometimes, or oftentimes,
depending on what is happening,
is a reminder of
those larger systems
in which folks haven't been
able to advance in the ways
that they should.
I don't look around
campus and notice
that there are few black
faculty and think we just
can't do this, it's because
there are certain systems that
are set up to prevent that or--
actively or passively.
And so I think the first
is different from the last
in that way.
Is that helpful?
BRADY BENNETT: Yes.
Very much so.
And I also just want to
ask being that you're here
at Google with us
today but you're
speaking to your
personal experiences
at the University of
Michigan, in what ways,
or if there are any,
are these misconceptions
or are these structures
being combated
on the university from not
only a student perspective,
but also from that
of a faculty member?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah.
So Michigan has been
a couple of years
into its diversity,
equity, and inclusion plan.
And those are things that
we see across the nation
in various places.
And I think a lot about
that in my research.
I think particularly about
how social justice education
programs-- which
I'm a part of one--
how they fare in this
space of diversity, equity,
and inclusion These spaces that
were built to teach students
how to think about--
or actually, to
push them to think
critically about these systems
that we live in and do it
through peer-to-peer learning.
I think a lot about how
educational spaces like that,
that were built
within the university
but built to push
back against some
of the institutional
racism that we see,
how they actually do under
diversity and equity inclusion
plans.
And interestingly, what we see
is that sometimes, the edge
sort of gets blunted off.
When we bring in some diversity,
equity, and inclusion programs,
we sometimes start to
see an incorporation
of the things that were
maybe most radical or most
challenging sort of get
swept up into that in a way
that some folks wouldn't
be comfortable with.
But I will say amongst
faculty at all times
and amongst staff at
all times, there's
always a contestation to that
type of institutional racism
that we see.
Whether it is by simply being
a part of the institution
and trying to create a way
for others to come into it
and thereby make it
different, or it's
trying to be supportive of
what students are doing.
Trying to be supportive of
policies and procedures that
are going to shift what
our campus looks like.
And not only what our campus
looks like but the ways
that we're participating
in our campus.
Or whether it's folks who are
questioning what's going on.
Whether they're questioning
policing on our campus,
or questioning who comes to
campus, or questioning what
is taught in our classrooms.
That's an incredibly
powerful tool
that faculty always have
at their disposal-- what
is taught in their classrooms.
So people are always
pushing back in those ways.
And I think it's important
to think about the ways
that we see that in an
institutionalized way
and the ways that we just see
it popping up from various folks
here and there and everywhere.
BRADY BENNETT: And then
also, being that many of us
here in the Ann Arbor
office at Google
are members of that
very community,
whether we be sprinkled
within or on the outskirts
of the university's campus.
With that in mind,
what ways, if any,
will we be able to find
a way to assist or lend
our services in any way in order
to build a greater cohesion
amongst our two communities?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah.
I would say keep conversations
like this going is
the first one.
But also, I would be
interested to know what
Google is doing in terms of DI.
But also off on
the sides of that,
what are the interactions
like between people?
Are you making time to
think about difference
and how it shows up in your
community, in your workspace?
And again, focusing
on what you're doing,
and then finding the natural
ways to bond with others.
So if Google is partnered up
with Michigan in some ways--
I don't know what
those ways might
be-- but if Google is
partnered up in those ways,
thinking about how to
make that partnership
one that benefits the
most marginalized folks
within Michigan's community.
And thinking about how to
further that at every turn,
and making that the
focus of your program.
So one, what are
you already doing?
And then how do you
shift that so it's
the most just way that you
can connect with the Michigan
community?
Those who are coming in.
Yeah.
So again, doing a lot
of the internal work,
and then transferring
that outward.
Does that make sense?
BRADY BENNETT: It does, it does.
Well, that is it for my
portion of the questions,
but I do want to
open the floor up
to anyone in the
audience who may just
have some questions pertaining
to the film in general or any
questions specifically
for Stephanie
that we can try to address.
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
Dr. Hicks, for coming.
I really appreciated the talk.
The questions that I have
is, often, black individuals
who are considered successful
and often navigate white spaces
are often called terms
like Oreo or accused
of talking white
by both individuals
in the dominant group, but also
by people in their own group
as well.
And so sometimes,
these terms will
be used by white individual
as terms of acceptance.
Like oh, no.
You're one of us.
You're an Oreo.
But often, if you really dissect
what the term Oreo means,
it really is associating
blackness with mediocrity
and whiteness with success.
And so how do we
reshape this narrative
where that is often the case?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah.
So again, this makes me think
about intergroup relations.
And right now, I'm actually
teaching foundations
of intergroup relations,
and our students
are thinking about
this very thing, right?
It's the moment where--
we've just past the
moment where we're
thinking about stereotypes,
and how they're activated,
and how they're formed.
And the students are, they're
hitting a wall, as we all do.
Because they're like, wait.
So you mean I've been learning
this from a very young age?
What is going on?
What does this mean?
And so we start to talk
about socialization-- the way
that we move through
those various institutions
that I talked about.
The legal system, our
educational system,
our religious institutions,
media, what have you.
And we realize that
we're getting--
much of our message
that we're getting,
we're getting from there.
And we're getting
them from people
that we know and respect, right?
So it's not just
someone's yelling
at you horrible things
about an out-group
and you're just taking them.
These things are
coming from spaces
that we know and trust, which
is what helps them continue.
So I think what we really
need to think about again
is socialization.
Who are we coming into
contact with at our earliest,
most formative stages, and
throughout our progression?
And how do we're not necessarily
shift who those people are--
we still want to be a
part of our communities--
but shift how we're
sharing those messages
and shift how we're combating
those messages at every turn?
So what that means,
though, is that we
have to change structures so
that those interactions are
different.
It's really hard to
have these interactions
with others that
help us see or get
a window into a
different perspective
if it's still couched in
the same larger system.
You're seeking out
information that
confirms what you already know.
So you just get this new
example and it's a one-off.
So we have to change schools.
We have to change what's
going on in homes.
We have to change how
we're consuming media.
But that means that we
have to first notice what
we're coming into contact with.
We have to notice
that it's a problem.
If we're not necessarily
thinking about the messages
that we receive through
media or the messages
school as being problematic,
we don't really have an
impetus to change them, right?
So we have to do a lot
of consciousness-raising.
But I think again that
comes from people--
that can come from these moments
of dissonance that we have.
But that can also just come
from starting to do the work.
Those of us who know that
we need something different
start the process of creating
those structures however
we see fit.
And that can be
one-by-one and two-by-two.
But even in a space like Google.
How are you impacting what
messages people get about what
it means to be black, and
the value of being black,
and what that means in
the context of whiteness?
How are you all
shaping those messages,
and how can you be a part of
how people are being socialized
around those things?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming.
[INAUDIBLE] has
[INAUDIBLE] in the office.
Some of us in this
room are parents.
And maybe you answered a
little bit of this question
in your last
response, but we would
love to hear what are the one,
two things that we can do--
sorry, I'm cutting in and out--
to really raise our children
to be more accepting of others?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Yeah.
So I'll say first, I'm
speaking as a non-parent.
So I just want to
name that, because I
want to be clear that I
don't know exactly what it's
like to be a parent.
But what I do think--
and this is something
that goes for everyone.
But I think in the
context of parenting,
it makes a lot of sense.
Talk to other parents.
Right?
So I think we often
have this perception,
or this understanding--
and I think it comes from
a well-intentioned place--
that the second we learn
all this new information,
we have to find the
biggest, boldest way
to shout it from the rooftops
and change everything
overnight.
Being a parent is an
incredibly powerful role.
So both because
of the interaction
that you have with
your children,
but because of the
interaction that you
have with other parents.
So I think one of the most
important things that you
can do is start to
talk to other parents
about what it is you're seeing.
What is it that you're
coming to understand?
What do you still
not understand?
What is still complex
and confusing?
And building power
within yourselves,
what might you do then to start
to unlearn some of the things
that you've learned?
I think it's a really
powerful question
when people start
to ask themselves,
How did we get here?
How did we find ourselves in
the situation that we're in?
Because that then helps you
identify both what's missing
and other folks who
share that same concern.
And then you can think
about, as parents,
what are your next best steps?
What are the ways that you're--
what are your parenting styles
like?
What are you doing
with your children?
And how could that
be in the service
of shifting some of these
messages that come around you?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much for coming.
My question is in the
height of the era where--
I'm sure you've heard this,
but racists aren't really scary
anymore, and they're kind of out
and showing themselves to us.
As an educator, do you come
across a lot of frustration
when it comes to
being the person who's
trying to teach people,
and does it feel like we're
kind of reverting back to
all of the work that was done
under the civil rights
movement or all the people that
kind of cleared the way for us?
Do you feel like
this radicalization
is making you take
huge steps back,
or do you feel like it's
opening the space for you
to have conversations
more freely?
STEPHANIE HICKS: Mm-hmm.
So I think the answer
is D, all the above.
So in terms of what it makes
me think of as an educator--
well, I should say this.
Before I was at the
University of Michigan,
I was at the
University of Illinois
at Chicago, which is a different
context and a different city.
I'm from Chicago.
I'm from the south
side of Chicago.
Yeah, Chicago!
[LAUGHTER]
So I was in that space, and my
student body looked different.
Because was it just a different
space and a different type
of institution.
So a lot of what's
happening-- or not what's
happening in my classroom, but a
lot of the classes that I teach
or the courses that I
teach, my student body just
looks different.
I look out into
classrooms that are filled
with more white students, filled
with more wealthy students,
and that is the nature of those
two different institutions.
And so I think that, sure.
I'm confronted with
different things.
But I also-- and I
do think that there
is a sense in which some
folks are more emboldened.
But I think we have to think
about the ways in which
white supremacy and all of
these various institutions
that we're talking about
show themselves every day,
and have shown themselves every
day before the current moment.
And they showed themselves in
sort of really nuanced ways
that come up even out of the
most sort of well-meaning ways.
So in my classroom,
actually, because I'm
teaching a lot of classes
that are around intergroup
relations, a lot of
students opt into them
and they want to
be a part of them.
I actually don't have
regular experiences
with my classroom with students
who hold those types of views,
though they do present
themselves definitely
around campus and in
the greater context.
But what I do see is the ways
that we are all implicated
in these systems every day.
And so sometimes,
actually, that can
be challenging and difficult to
work with in a different way.
Because we're all
working on the assumption
that we're really good people.
And we're really good people
who don't hold particular ideas.
And we want to stop the
bad thing over there.
Racism is the bad
thing over there,
and racists are the
bad people over there
that we want to stop.
And when we're working
from that place,
we can sort of fail to see
how we allow these messages
that the dominant culture
gives to impact all that we do,
whether we are actively
doing it or not.
So yes.
I do see some things that
make me think, one, I'm tired
and I don't want to get up
in front of this classroom
and teach this again.
Some days I definitely
have that struggle.
But I also think that my
job provides a lot of hope.
Because what I do
see often, too,
are a lot of folks who are part
of a dominant culture who are
trying to think differently.
So it's a mixed bag.
It really, really is.
So I see both.
Yeah.
BRADY BENNETT: Well, it
looks like we're just
coming up on time.
So again, thank you
so much, Stephanie,
for joining us today.
This discussion was very
helpful, very powerful.
I hope that it is of some
service to you and the audience
today.
But again, thank
you all for coming,
and enjoy the rest of your day.
[APPLAUSE]